I look around and I see a desperate lack
of Hope it really really troubles me but
I think what we're missing is that when
we say our politicians are behaving
disgracefully and that's also broken
they're just reflecting the society
that's voting them in we're missing that
it's telling us something about our own
Society
so if you don't engage respectfully if
you don't think through the issues if
you don't grapple with the facts rather
than the emotions
there's your civilizational moment we're
not thinking we're emoting everything
and that's your classic with social
media
I think there's another aspect there's
the old Edmund Burke thing you know all
it takes for evil to prosper is good
people to remain silent so you've got a
huge number of people who are disengaged
from politics from public life from the
Public Square
and they're frightened of going on
social media and what we actually need
is more people of balance from the
middle being prepared to say you know I
don't like all this stuff out there and
I'm just going to go online and say Hey
listen Carmen let's think this through
laughs
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm Constance
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our terrific guest today is a
former deputy Prime Minister of
Australia who's now become a YouTuber
how far he has fallen John Anderson
welcome to trigonometry it's fantastic
to be with you both oh it's so great to
have you on the show you've interviewed
me a couple of times we've met we know
each other well uh welcome to the show
first of all uh for anyone who's not
familiar with you you host a brilliant
YouTube show called conversations uh
which is what we tried to do here but
tell everybody who are you how are you
where you are what has been your journey
through life because you've done a hell
of a lot of things many of them very
interesting well I'm actually a farmer
by background or an Australian farming
terminology I suppose I'm a farmer in
grazia cropping and animals uh and uh
you know I sometimes quip that when I'm
out on the farm people say I can't see
you in a suit and I look like this they
say ah you're not a farmer You Know
You're Something Dreadful like a banker
or a lawyer or whatever so I'm a bit
schizophrenic uh but I I'm a sixth
generation on the land in Australia
Scottish extraction
uh and a product of the University of
Sydney uh a lover of history and a
public life fascinates me uh great to
devote to you of the democratic
tradition and frankly of
a mixed market economy uh controlled
capitalism I suppose you'd say uh found
myself in public life more by accident
than design I'd never gone looking for
it I was talked into it literally talked
into it
uh and if you told me when I was young
I'd end up a having 10 years as a
cabinet minister and six as Deputy Prime
Minister I would have said you had rocks
in your head and a lot of people would
have would probably still say it should
never have happened but it did and I
left at a time when Australia was in a
Purple Patch it was going really well
and I'd had enough of public life I
wanted some family life back I wanted to
go back to farming uh and then the great
financial crisis hit
and I saw the fishes in Western Society
because I it should never have happened
and B when it had we wouldn't accept our
responsibilities to clean up the mess
pay down all the debt engage in good
policy to restore our strength and I'm
talking the West generally I'm frankly
talking about my own country I'm talking
about America Canada Britain in
particular Europe as well uh and so a
friend and I started
our series of conversations and
the idea is more than anything else is
just to provide a conduit for good
thinking so I don't have a model where I
sort of interrupt or try to interfere or
play any entrapment games
let the audience let those who listen do
their own interpreting what's the idea
it's to encourage thinking because we're
doing too much emoting at the moment
well that's something we're definitely
going to get into but John one of the
things that you and I have often talked
about and Francis and I were very keen
to ask you about is we've talked many
times about the fact that there's a
culture of victimhood wallowing in in
terrible bad things that our countries
did and also in our own personal lives
and you're actually somebody who has a
child experienced an awful lot of
tragedy didn't you I did yeah yeah would
you mind telling us about that and how
you overcame that and how you you went
on to be who you are well that's really
a story of personal faith so if you're
up for it I'll I'll give you the
encapsulated version because we are so
we're going to get the punishment we
deserve
um I suppose in a way you know the the
point of the story is to say we're very
judgmental when we say you're a victim
and you're not a victim because we don't
know what other people have been through
you know man I don't know what tough
times and you know I know a little of
your story back in Russia that wasn't
easy you know people could say oh look
at this privileged Westerner in London
living it up and he's got millions of
followers so in my case my parents lives
badly interrupted badly by the second
world war
um so marriage was very delayed for them
I was born 10 years after the war I'm a
mid baby boomer my mother died very
shortly afterwards of undiagnosed
stomach cancer leaving my sister and me
who's very young
and that was very tough for my father
really tough we lived in a fairly
isolated part of Australia
anyway we were sent off to boarding
school because that's what you had to do
when you got to age 11 or 12 in Sydney
and home on holidays my father was a um
a very gifted Sportsman so every
afternoon he was a good dad in this
sense would go off Target practicing we
had a rabbit plague in Australia so we'd
be popping off rabbits along the Creeks
all would be boxing he was a printed
boxer always be playing cricket because
he was a brilliant cricketer
staggeringly good eye for ball and as a
teenager we were practicing Cricket
during one Easter break
uh and I was building my father all over
the place and he had that smile that a
father gets when he sees his kids really
latched onto something and then it all
went horribly horribly wrong
and I hit a six and my slightly younger
sister we were very close to an age uh
was watching from Sidelines a long way
away playing with a cat and she looked
up and saw my sixth Stitcher coming
straight for her and instinctively
turned away
and that the ball quarter in the back of
the neck and she staggered a few feet
towards my father and called out and
died
and that was an extraordinary experience
and very few people go through where
you've been the innocent
cause of someone else's death and I was
innocent and I don't say for a moment I
had a guilt up hangover just the utter
misery of going to a place where you
think no matter how nice people are to
me they don't know what this is like
because so people have been there and
where your childhood just pins
and it impacts your sense of humor so I
love other people with a sense of humor
but I'm very aware that I didn't
practice mine very well as a young
person and I had to go looking for
answers to the big questions I couldn't
avoid them they were there and I thought
this is either going to sink me
or I'm going to find a resolution and
find a way through and for me that was
the source really
from a thoroughly secular family I
suppose you'd say of me coming to
personal faith as a Christian believer
wow and
was that then your faith a platform for
you to be able to go and succeed in life
as your faith always been the Bedrock
for you
I think the answer to that is yes and I
think in many ways
the thing it's done most For Me Against
the Grain of my own nature
I think is to say
that my neighbor matters
and that I should be careful not about
so much judging their actions sometimes
I don't even be as tough as you like in
saying to others I think that's a bad
thing to do but not to write them off as
people and to say that if I matter
because a part of this journey for me
was to discover that this was not the
way it was meant to be God intended
things to be better that's my belief
that standard Christian belief we broke
it by our own selfishness but
part of that the the the Deep desire to
see others flourish and to participate
in a society where you're building not
pair tearing down became a very strong
motivation for me
and I sometimes think to myself
I feel the hurt of unwarranted I've
never had much trouble cutting with
deserved criticism but when it's
undeserved or unfair or unjustified or
people in wrong motivation to me I've
always found that hard because quickly
enough I've actually been very deeply
committed to the idea of trying to help
build a better world I find that that
response quite surprising John because
you're saying that you find undeserved
criticism difficult to deal with and yet
you went into politics
yeah well it's a good point yeah but I
think the point I would make is that
when I copped Flack for something I'd
got wrong
you know I'd be remorseful and tail
between the leg and what have you but I
I could cope with it better than when
somebody made an accusation that was
just false or wrong or imputed to me
uh you know motivations that that I felt
were unfair hmm you know base
motivations and sometimes I'd have to
pull myself up and say actually this is
saying a lot more about them than it is
about me
and John as we sit here recording this
we've just spent a few weeks in America
and in America people are very
comfortable expressing their religious
Faith openly but with you I sense of
hesitation is that just because you're
sitting here with two filthy agnostics
or or is there are we now you know in
Australia and Britain are we a little
bit more hesitant perhaps to talk about
things like that do you think uh look
there is a fair bit of that no it's not
you guys I know you're in trust you and
care enough about you to know that
anything is about me will be good
natured it will once
he doesn't know you though I've got a
division here you know there's always
looks for division yeah I'm an
ex-politician yeah um uh look I'm just
aware that my story can be you know it's
a hard one to tell
uh it is to talk about those things
openly I'll tell you partly why I do it
more recently it's because I've seen
Jordan Peterson addressing
packed houses as mainly younger people
and I've noticed that young men in
particular respond when he tells them
that life's tough and it's gritty uh and
don't pretend otherwise and that truth I
think his line is truth is the antidote
to suffering and as I've watched in
Australia those young men responding to
him I'm thinking they're wanting what I
would say is a real steak not thin gruel
they're wanting to know other people's
experiences they want to know the
unvarnished truth
um and I suppose that's that's part of
why I tell it but the other part of it
is that I know that a lot of people
particularly not so much in America but
in Australia and in Britain will say oh
we've moved on from that hug you know
John you're just being superstitious
it's rubbish and so forth but to me it
is the core of my being I had to answer
three very tough questions after that
what is this suffering why is suffering
so real
you know and secondly does anybody care
does anybody understand
and thirdly will the words be bound up
will there be Joy
and I think the answer to those three
questions in short or is
um no this is not the way it was meant
to be but we broke the world and people
will sort of say what are you talking
about original sin and I suppose yes I
am uh and it's not a complete
explanation in my case why did I live in
my sister not live I don't know I hope I
may won't know one day but here's the
point
what would really kill me would be the
idea to think it was just totally random
no purpose you just have all this pain
because that's the way life is and that
was the way it was always meant to be
now I don't believe it was meant to be
like that secondly can it be restored
does anybody care can it be restored
second part of the Triangle Well I
believe yes I do believe the Christian
message of redemption I do believe that
the most central figure in history is
Christ
and he suffered
in every way in a way that's beyond
anything I might suffer a new alienation
then rejection by his friends more than
anything I might know
um so he can identify uh and because of
his actions I I do believe the wounds
can be bound up and that there is hope
and I look around and I see a desperate
lack of Hope
it really really troubles me I used to
see it all the time as an MP in the
really disadvantaged parts of my
electorate including and this is a
sensitive issue in Australia amongst
indigenous kids and I'd see them in the
school and their lives being
you know pissed up against the wall by
what was happening at home in their
community and I'm sorry to say that even
in the schools despite well-meaning
teachers and you think this is just a
dead end Street no wonder they've got no
hope
and hope is so important we don't talk
about it enough no we don't and with
that religious bit that we just did we
lost all our British audience but
welcome Americans it's good to have you
on board there must be some Brits
six of them exactly
you can just write a list down but you
know the other thing I think about you
know I I don't know if I'm projecting
this onto you but I think you come from
a generation us less so but still where
the idea of talking about difficult
things that you've experienced it wasn't
really what the done thing no it wasn't
that's right but I do start to get the
sense that as you say Jordan Peterson
and others and you know I tried to do a
bit of this in my office speech as well
which we've talked about privately to
give some examples that are much more
real rather than sort of theory and talk
about the difficulties that we all go
through
um so it's very easy for people to look
at me and my wife and my kids and
grandkids and say it's all picture
perfect that's right yeah that's where I
was going
tell me more
well that's partly why I want to say to
people
look can we draw alongside
and I want to acknowledge that you're
doing it tough and I don't want you to
think that I haven't known what it is to
have to ask a big questions just because
you know I in many ways materially I've
never wanted for anywhere you know I've
been very fortunate in that regard but
that's the life's about much more than
that and you know this business of
creating victims selected very carefully
selected victims who are then weaponized
that is such a feature of a modern
so-called Progressive society and we say
we care do we
and when we carefully select our victims
and we say this is the Jordan Peterson
things when you see him in front of an
audience of hundreds and hundreds of
young people and they're all there
because he's not saying your
masculinity's toxic you're toxic just
because you're a young Australian Mahal
which is the message they're getting
you know that's what they're hearing and
he's saying to them you know that's not
right I I don't think a victim culture
is going to fix your problems and B life
is tough let me acknowledge that
so then we can talk
because life does present us with big
challenges it's not just material I
agree with you it presents us with huge
challenges and one of the big challenges
that is presenting us with is politics
does seem to be broken at the moment
John and as somebody who used to work in
politics what's going wrong with it now
we had a member when I was in the
Parliament and um
uh whenever a constituent asking
something he'd say I'll bring it up in
the house so they called him spirited
when they realized that he realized he
was being called spury he changed it he
said um I'll look into it so they called
him mirror
that yeah the point of that yarn is that
what I think we miss
is that in the democratic tradition
which I say we're privileged to live in
and the West I know people are losing
confidence in it now young people
especially
Democratic capitalism they're not
invested in it anymore because it's not
working for them well and there's a bit
of Truth in that and we ought to be
honest about it but I think what we're
missing is that when we say our
politicians are behaving disgracefully
and that's also broken they're just
reflecting the society that's voting
them in we're missing that it's telling
us something about our own society and
I'll tell you one of the biggest things
that's telling us we're raising our kids
in Contra distinction to the way that I
was raised not all I mean I know I got
gray hair and I'm older than you guys
but in the great scheme of things it's
not all that long ago I was educated in
the 60s and 70s and a big part of the
education was don't think you're more
special than the person sitting on the
desk next to you in the classroom now
it's you're the center of your Universe
if not the universe you know it's all
about you you know the whole radical
autonomy idea uh and uh finds yourself
from within and go out and be your own
God
but when we see it in our leaders up on
the stage and we say they seem to think
it's more about them no it's not they
should be serving us
hang on
they're actually mirroring us that's
what we become why should we be
surprised
and look at the way the Queen's memorial
service I don't know how they work those
things out but apparently it was what's
by four billion people she's hugely
admired
how would you describe a leadership with
servant leadership and when we see it we
say yeah that's right that's the way it
ought to be she was committed to working
hard for us
a lifetime of dedicated service to
others you can't escape it and we
admired a hugely for it and we're not
seeing that in enough of our politicians
I'm not going to blackard them all I
know some very good ones I really do who
are genuinely trying to make a
difference but there are too many of
them now that are there about power
and that's the other problem you have
you know when you've got no God over
government government becomes God and
the people in it become about power and
principle disappears see we used to
argue on principle sometimes for
minority groups increasingly
and unfortunately hurts me to say this a
bit but I think it probably applies to
politicians on both sides of the aisle
all too often it's really about power
and that's we don't like that and we
shouldn't like it we should be worried
about it
that's why our forebears set all these
checks and balances in place
as one person said of Democracy in
America we're so good we had to give
ourselves the vote you know we recognize
the dignity and the worth of everyone
we're so bad we had to give ourselves a
vote we need a peaceful Marines of
breaking up power and ensuring that no
one can hold it for too long and we can
arrange for changing our leaders at the
point of a pencil not a gun and we ought
to be in love with that system
but we've got this double-sided problem
we keep promoting the wrong people and
then they keep doing the wrong thing and
we all get more and more cynical but
isn't also the problem as well John in
that we are we have become a society
that is pleasure seeking we love closure
we don't want to endure a moment of
discomfort that being the case
what do you do as a politician when
you've got some uncomfortable troops you
need to tell people about their society
and particularly let's be honest about
the economic situation we find ourselves
in I couldn't agree with you more I
think this is a really serious problem
that was a heart I didn't Pat it out
much but in back home I've got this
conversation series and and Constantine
you've been honored and we've just loved
having you
um and um you know we've got this uh
this whole sort of problem of trying to
get people to
think a little bit more deeply about
tomorrow
and this business of Living Way beyond
our means
you know we're borrowing not just
against our children but Against The
Unborn as that doesn't matter we matter
more than they do that's not what our
forebears said
they were prepared to say we've got to
take a long-term viewer just like
parents do you've got a little boy now
Constantine which I think is fantastic
and
um but try and convince him to have some
kids yeah Britain you need to get your
population rate up you know nobody's
worked it out yet but there's a
depopulation bomb about to hit most of
the world not Africa and not some parts
of the Middle East maybe South America
but everywhere else and it's going to be
a real problem but we're not invested in
the future
and being invested in the future means
family and kids actually matter and you
now know very deeply what you'd do for
your boy
and that other person centeredness
is something that we really need to
learn very deeply if if cultures like
ours are to survive and thrive
hey Francis do you want to learn another
language no mate we voted brexit for a
reason well if you are open-minded
unlike Francis and want to learn another
language then Babel is the app for you
why would anyone want to learn that
foreign filth what's next eating snails
and frogs what kind of person goes
looking for food in the local pond dead
points for breakfast weird Babble makes
learning a language quick and easy
because it focuses on natural
conversation 15-minute lessons are
designed to be the most efficient and
effective way to learn a new language
lessons are created by over 150 language
experts meaning real people synop the
French so you learn how to have a real
world conversation things you'll
actually use not meaningless phrases
isn't even the word mate the great thing
about Babel is that the lessons are
interactive they aren't just robots
talking they're voiced by native
speakers using a modern conversation
based method so in no time you'll be
speaking confidently about real life
topics in another language with Babel
you can choose from 14 different
languages including Spanish French
Italian and German even though that's
not a real language plus Babel speech
recognition technology helps you to
improve your pronunciation and action in
next to no time you'll be speaking
German just like I speak English yeah
we're trying to sell the product mate
there are so many ways to learn with
Babel in addition to lessons you can
access podcasts Games videos or even
join live classes with a language
teacher start your new language learning
Journey with Babel today right now Babel
is offering
six months free with a
with a promo
code go to babble.com play and use promo
code trigger for an extra six months
free that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash play promo code
trigger Babel language learning that
works
isn't that amazing John that you know
the vast majority of people in this
country in Australia and America where
this is happening are parents and yet we
are consciously as a society saddling
our own children and as you say unborn
grandchildren with if if you said to me
Constantine are you prepared to saddle
your son with hundreds of thousands of
pounds of debt for your own immediate
satisfaction pleasure whatever so you
can have a nicer house I don't think
there's a parent in the world who would
do that very few I imagine I hope so yet
as a society that is exactly what we're
doing
yeah but this is part of the problem
we're emoting everything I feel I need
more support from the government
but I don't think on the other hand that
it's actually other taxpayers money
and that is now being borrowed under
that money's got to be serviced the
fastest growing area I was part of a
government that left Australia with no
debt and Money in the Bank
it's one of the five people co-opted by
the then prime minister in 1996 gone
wind back the deficits and then we'll
see if we can pay down the debt we got
rid of the lot over 11 years left money
in the bank
and now that's been lazy squandered uh
and so we've got a big debt again and I
find that extraordinary because it is
really
impacting on taxpayers today and our
children because the fastest growing
area of expenditure in Australia is the
interest on the debt
so the taxpayers have got to find a
whole heap of money before you build a
hospital or pay nurses or provide police
or buy a destroyer for the Navy before
you do anything you've got to Fork out a
whole lot of hard-earned money
and our kids and our grandkids if we
don't rein this in
we'll have to fall out even more
and it says something very profound
about our culture that we've reached
that point where it doesn't matter I
couldn't agree more and this brings us
to a question I was going to ask you
because the government that you were
part of and your political career all
happened pre the social media age yeah
and I can't help thinking that social
media has been a huge part of what
you're talking about because social
media rewards things that sound good but
don't work in practice social media
encourages not just you know politics
has always been adversarial and that's a
good thing in in a liberal Society you
want different points of view but it's
not adversarial anymore it's it's now
hostile you are the enemy because you're
on the right and I am the enemy because
I'm on the left and and the point of
speaking in public now in in a
parliament is no longer about persuading
or or articulating a principal point of
view it's about getting a good clip for
social media which shows you destroying
the evil bigoted or stupid or whatever
the other side how much of this do you
think is a product of the changing
technological landscape I have in the
past often just said look all it's been
is an amplifier of trends that were
there but I'm increasingly thinking that
it's been a part of the problem and
bigger and bigger part of the problem in
its own right
and an example that really occurs to me
is the issue of free speech now they
tell me in America that majority support
for free speech
on American campuses you can actually
the the went to minority speech about 10
years ago about 2013-14 how on Earth can
you say it was such a narrow period of
time leaving alone the questions of why
it happened
it's got to be largely social media
because so many people use that ability
to hit others without a sense of
responsibility and respect
that suddenly people are saying I've
been destroyed or my friends have been
destroyed or I'm terrified of being
restored by the way people use this
thing therefore
let's abandon free speech and say it
should only be appropriate speech and in
a way you can understand it alisonic
right now he says good great don't you
understand that means some orwellian
vision and someone out there will
determine what's appropriate but they're
not thinking that many of them they'd be
thinking I just want some protection
from the possibility of being torn apart
so we're not using the technology wisely
we're using it to feed our worst
instincts in an age when we've lost
respect for one another and it's the old
you know the old um it's a cliched I
know and it's attributed of Voltaire and
it wasn't him but uh you know I may
disagree with you but I'll defend her
the death you're right so it's now if
you dare to disagree with me I'll do
everything I can to destroy you and they
are Polar Opposites and until we can
recover some common understanding of our
shared Humanity
see one of the things that I've really
noticed in in politics in Australia
I used to have some really spirited but
enjoyable conversations with people who
had a totally different world view to me
but in their own way they were Noble
they wanted to build a better way as
they saw it and I'm talking about
you know people from the serious left as
the left was then it was about
universalism let's lift the
disadvantaged up so they're part of the
family and some of those people will say
say now their own movement is so
distorted it's now about creating an
aristocracy of victims and then
weaponizing them it's never about
solving their problems because you
solved their problems they're not
victims and you lost your weapon and
what a terrible thing to do to other
people
and and somehow we've got to rebuild
that respect
and it's the same with uh with with
something like private property we
should respect I mean on the Four
Freedoms free speech to my way of
thinking freedom of conscience and
belief freedom to associate and and
freedom to own private property
including
your intellectual prowess you know
you're using yours highly effect it's
yours
it's not for a government to come along
and shut you down or take away your
private property or whatever it's yours
to use wisely well
you know weaken any of those freedoms
and you weaken them all it's like a
four-legged stool you know you break one
and the stool will fall over
but we don't talk like that anymore and
Australia in particular has fallen
victim to this which I know because when
I was growing up I saw these Aussie
blokes as being these kind of ruggedly
masculine dare I say tomb haskelling
right loving a punch up in a beer and
whatever else and now you've got
Melbourne which I mean is is it the
wokest place on Earth practically
wow
um there are Regional differences
[Music]
yeah
um
yeah well you know it is extraordinary I
I was in America recently and I had a
two-hour interview with Patrick Bett
Davis uh in in Miami and he called the
show whatever happened to the
Australians
and I don't know how many Australians
understand that you know that we've got
this image now around the world of of
the most severe lockdowns and you're
going to only walk for an hour a day why
not you know an hour and one minute you
know and why not five and a half
kilometers away from home instead of
five kilometers and then you know
pregnant women being dragged Away by
police and what have you one Facebook
post and this pregnant woman is now in
deep trouble you're under arrest in
relation to incitement incitement what's
that what on Earth excuse me what what
on Earth I just put your phone in can
you like in my pajamas what's this
ultrasound
yeah she's pregnant so
what's this about ultrasound in an hour
let me finish in last night stimulation
to a Facebook post in relation to a
lockdown protest that's why I'm
arresting you Innovation how can you
arrest her that's my two children she
could face a jail sentence of up to 15
years
but they voted for more of it sort of
Stockholm syndrome you know the the the
regime that put it in place has been
subjected to an election and they want
it again partly because the opposition
didn't stand for enough but partly
because people
who was the American forefather I think
was Benjamin Franklin that people who
become afraid and go looking for
security over Freedom are worthy of
neither
um
I think we've lost sight of how valuable
Freedom which is why I've enjoyed my
conversation so much Constantine with
you as we've talked in the past about
your home environment and you've written
this marvelous book which I really you
sent it to me and I really you know it
survived the British and Australian
money it arrived at home on my farm in
northwest New South Wales and I read it
and I thought isn't this terrific
because you can see as so often those
who are sitting in the luxury spot when
everything else seems comfortable
how our own slothfulness is placing at
risk of very things that we enjoy well
it's very kind of you and I've just
started writing my second book so I look
forward to sending you that as well but
it may not arrive after this
conversation it may not but come back to
me with me to the social media
conversation because you're one of the
few people we avoid having politicians
on the show because increasingly it's
hard to get a straight answer
well I'm sure you do and I haven't tell
us why tell us why you avoid having
politicians ah look in my case it's
largely because I have one on there'll
be others who want to and I don't
particularly because you know I'm
obviously very close to some of them
still and and I have you know people
that I talk to all the time and they
kindly ring and say you tried some of
them are wise enough to actually say
there's nothing new Under the Sun John I
think you might have tried this what
happened you know I've only more of them
did it
because very often it's not me being
clever I was just saying yeah sure we
tried that and here's where it went
wrong right and all that experience was
washed out of the system we used to
listen to
can I call myself an elder I'm old I
don't know what I can call myself I
certainly would yeah
well the old bitter oil anyway
um so but you know the other reason is
that um
you know I'm trying to provide a service
to some of the good politicians and and
their staffers because I know a lot of
them do listen in in Australia there'll
be surprising number of people on the
hill in Canberra who will listen to this
conversation
and that's good uh but I I and part of
it is I I want to be a bit bipartisan
about it so I've spoken to quite a few
number quite a number of ex-politicians
that I really respect from both sides
including one from the old-fashioned
hard left perspective
but maybe they're just delighted on
balance that I don't want them on so no
well that makes sense for us the reason
we don't is it's hard to get Australians
of them out of them quite often but you
are one of the few people that we've
ever spoken to on the show who's
actually been in a senior leadership
position in running a country right and
the reason I want to talk about social
media is to me it's the central
conundrum and until AI takes over and
makes things even worse the central
conundrum of the age that we're living
in and I don't really understand how you
might go about addressing that because
we talk about free speech and Francis
and I as you know are huge Believers and
I think it's essential but I'm also
increasingly convinced that a free
internet of the sort of that we had in
the early days of the internet is never
coming back it's not going to happen
because the technology is too powerful
we saw it during the pandemic when you
know David Ike says something about how
covert is caused by 5G masks the next
day you've got people burning things
down better to be safe than sorry
ha
he's joking YouTube
see what I mean yeah the technology is
very powerful yes it is uh we saw it
summer people would argue January the
6th is an example of this right a a
thing that's whipped up on the Internet
whatever you think happened on that day
was not a good thing to have happened
happens in the real world and it's been
happening in Australia on a regular
basis there's a little show somewhere
that suddenly gets out blown out of all
proportion and everyone's polarized and
nobody's understood what truly happened
right and the politician Instinct I
imagine is to go well
we must do something about this right
but what do you do the moment you start
interfering it some people are going to
say well you're restricting our Free
Speech the moment you don't restrict
Free Speech other people are going to
say you're allowing things to happen
that are damaging in the real world you
know suicides and terrible tragedies and
you know protests that go violent and
all of this stuff how does a political
operative look at this problem and
actually try to address it
I wish I knew I don't have a good answer
I just don't because I think like all
technology the technology of source
neutral it's morally neutral it's what
you do with it so that comes down to our
sense of responsibility but we don't
talk responsibility anymore we only talk
freedoms and rights so somehow the the
answer is probably I mean the the only
parallel with this is a printing press
which through Europe into chaos for 100
years let's hope this modern version
doesn't do the same thing a modern
version of upgraded Communications if I
can put it that way we let's hope we can
find a resolution faster than that
because it's a fast-moving world and
it's very dangerous and for a long time
my view was very much the tech company
should be told well you like the postal
service and this is a dominant
you know it's got nothing to do with you
what's written in those letters nothing
to do you're the carrier
but that's too simplistic as well
because the bombs now can be embedded in
bad ideas
who decides what's a bad idea you're
into orwellian territory before you know
it
so I think I'm too old to answer the
question that's a cop-out I know there
you go you're probably half expected but
I think the answer long term has to lie
in US accepting because I think this is
a civilizational moment frankly I think
it's that serious why do you think it's
a civilizational moment John
because I think we're so cynical about
the values of the past or so disengaged
from them and we've not found any
guiding values for the present and this
is one of them
and I think a big part of the common
cause we made in the past was the
respect for people that you disagreed
with the genius of Western society and
Constantine you know about this because
of your own background was our capacity
for people who had very different World
Views to coexist and resolve their
differences through the political
process through the parliaments and what
have you and the Public Square I suppose
it went from being a literal Public
Square and the arigopolis if I've said
that right you know in ancient times
through to our parliaments then added to
by newspapers then radio then television
and now the Public Square is just a
chaotic Global thing that the very thing
we're talking about social media is
developed and we have not managed to
find some rules for it
but we can draw some principles from the
previous ones if you don't engage
respectfully if you don't think through
the issues if you don't grapple with the
facts rather than the emotions
there's your civilizational moment we're
not thinking
we're emoting everything
and that's your classic with social
media we're not thinking about what will
it mean if I put this stuff up there
we're thinking about will it give me a
hit will it make me feel good will it
destroy someone else
rather than will it build a stronger
Society based on respect and regard for
one another it's a pretty boring answer
I know a little bit but on the other
hand it's something I've increasingly
have come to I you know when we started
this I was quite readily trolling people
and making fun and whatever you know
satirically that's kind of what you're
supposed to do but the longer we go the
more I see the way the world is going
and also the bigger my audience grows
I've become far more responsible and
that was the word that you said there
which I think
you know we always look to government to
solve these problems actually it sounds
to me like the biggest solution is
within every human being which is to say
I am responsible for the things that I'm
communicating and yes this device makes
me angrier and more hostile and whatever
but it is my duty as a human being to
seek to be careful about the way that I
use this neutral technology
I think that's right I think there's
another aspect there's the old Edmund
Burke thing you know all it takes for
evil to prosper is good people to remain
silent so you've got a huge number of
people who are disengaged from politics
from public life from the Public Square
and they're frightened of going on
social media and what we actually need
is more people of balance from the
middle being prepared to say you know I
don't like all this stuff out there and
I'm just going to go online and say Hey
listen Karma let's think this through
because I think there's a bit of a
tendency now for people who want to win
the battle at the risk of losing the war
you know we're turning every battle into
I've got to win this even if I destroy
the other person
but often that's very counterproductive
to a harmonious society in which we can
all flourish
John we have now been made to feel
guilty for the sins of our ancestors
yeah and that has been a recurring theme
and it and it has just erupted
over the last couple of years how has
that affected Australia particularly
when it comes to the indigenous
communities we have the same disease
it's very bad policy to hold someone
responsible for what their forebears
have done you start going down that road
there's no end to the misery we will
inflict on one another and in many ways
the greatest problem with it is that you
start to withdraw agency we're talking
responsibility so people fall into you
know this is a victim culture again it's
identity politics oh it's not my fault
that you know I'm an abusive man in my
home
and I'm doing appalling things to you
know my own children and the neighbors
children and what have you I'm a victim
of Frontier violence or whatever
and just when we're making tremendous
progress on this is the Douglas Murray
point isn't it tremendous progress on a
whole lot of these issues you know we've
moved an incredible distance on the
issue of of you like overcoming racism
embedded racism and so forth incredible
distance in my own country I genuinely
believe that
um suddenly in the eyes of the activists
it's as though goodness me as Douglas
Murray puts it the trains coming gently
into the station's about to slow down
we've got this all wrong we've got to
put our foot on the throttle and take
the train off faster than ever and say
that we're more racist than ever
and
I do think that's a big part of the
problem and it's very easy for people to
say well I don't have to accept
responsibility from our actions I'm like
this because of what someone else has
done
um to my ancestors what their ancestors
have done to my ancestors
that's hopeless
that's hopeless we all need to be
accountable for the way we treat our
fellow human beings now
because there's a lot of people who go
and there's not even ancestors of people
Aborigines or people from that Community
will go look it's not even that far into
the past that we were treated
accordingly so let's can we have an
honest discussion about this and also
let's explode a few myths because
there's this perception that Australia
is a deeply racist culture and Country
and etc etc and I think the vast
majority of people who say those views
don't really know what they're talking
about well you can say the same of
America no there is racism I mean you
found it everywhere but what is racism
it's hatred of another person
what's the difference between hating
somebody of your same skin color and
somebody who's not by the way and a lot
of the people who Band Knee around this
very very pejorative sort of you're a
racist if you say that or if you go
anywhere or if you raise that question
they're actually displaying
their own level of vitriol and hatred
towards another person by refusing to
engage with the mind
and looking to appeal to Raw emotion
again now I think that's a real problem
the second thing I would say is that if
you look at the amount of resources the
amount of effort the amount of land
title and so forth in Australia it's
been made available to indigenous people
and I want to say I this man it's quite
raw for me I I actually really do care
my family have been enmeshed with
Aboriginal people for a long time none
of Australia's most prominent
aboriginals calls me Co which is short
for cousin because he says to me our
families have been into mesh for so long
and I value his friendship enormously
but
and you know I went to school with
Aboriginal people and I represented a
lot of them so I actually I really do
care but what I'm worried about is what
a most prominent Aboriginal leader I
suppose you'd say I think Noel Pearson
and he and I disagree on a lot of things
but he says you know welfare culture has
actually destroyed his people
so but what's that tell you it means
that we've actually been almost too
generous his words not mine secondly you
would say
I don't think I'm misrepresenting him
here you've got to restore agency you
can't indulge the idea that you're a
victim
of what somebody else's forebeest did to
your forebears we are each responsible
you know and we should be prepared to
give account for the way we behave
towards other people
so I don't see a lack of generosity in
Australians I see just the opposite you
know and willingness to spend a very
large amount of money and often it's
been misdirected we know that now you
can't get away from it often's made
problems worse
uh one of our best thinkers from the
very different political perspective to
mine as a man called Peter Sutton and he
wrote recently that the determinant of
bad outcomes
is to do with family and Community
environments not the color of skin in
Australia and I I do believe that to be
true
it's not to say there aren't major
issues there are
but I think it requires all of us to
accept that
denying you know blaming others all the
time
well you have a justice system if it's
true to try and sort it out
but we have to be responsible for our
own actions
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country would
judge Men's Health by his ability to
wrestle better in London I have since
found out this has very different
meaning we've all had a knight that's
got out of hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my unsuspect well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 is simple and easy way to
get all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Foods sourced
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we used it on our America talk
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we heard hugely successful trip it is
very economical and I felt strong enough
to wrestle America which we all know is
grotosely weak compared to Great Russian
Bear if you're looking for a simpler and
cost effective supplement routine ag1 is
giving you a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to drink
ag1.com
trigonometry if you're looking for a
simpler effective investment for your
health try edgy1 and get five free edu1
travel packs and a free one-year supply
of vitamin D with your first purchase go
to drink ag1.com trigonometry that's
drink ag1.com
trigonometry check it out yes check it
out and become real men like me
that being the case what do you think
about this referendum that's appearing
on the horizon I think it's in October
November 2023 which is our Aboriginal
voice is it not so just explain to
people what it is and whether you agree
with it whether you disagree with it Etc
well for start it's very hard to Define
what it is because in fact
the Prime Minister says it's a modest
proposal that just recognizes
aboriginals in the Constitution for
example the people who put it together
say no it's a major proposal which will
Empower us in a way we haven't been
before
um the lawyers are having a picnic
because some lawyers are saying this is
sound law others are saying it will lead
to endless activism I'm simply reporting
the facts there that's very easily
checked there's no agreement on what it
is or what impact it will have
um I am opposed to it
for three reasons the first is the
reasons I've just given the denial of
agency and what have you means I've and
I've had a lot of experience with this I
have had a lot of experience
and I've seen it on the ground and
aboriginality is not a nation
there are in fact three to four hundred
Nations
um and they are many of them proudly
individualistic so I don't know how 54
people are going to represent 300 plus
Nations
and have a special voice that no other
Australian has the second thing is that
the debate has been highly emotionally
charged and there have been the put
Downs if you're against this you're a
racist well I'm against it because I
don't think it's going to work
and for the third reason I don't think
constitutions I think good constitutions
they only work in the culture I mean
Russia had a great Constitution you
would know that but it wasn't a free
country it only work in the culture in
which they're embedded that's right
um and but our constitution was put
together I mean we're one of the oldest
democracies in the world Australia and
we were able to draw on the absolute
best internationally
particularly from the American you know
Declaration of Independence and
everything that came out of sorry out of
the out of the well out of that process
and drawing on the British model as well
but it was late in the piece
and I am on recorder saying and I repeat
here that in my view a constitution
should be a dry Dusty document that
draws no distinctions at all based on
wealth where you live gender position in
society all the color of your skin the
very model of equality
is to ensure that no one's singled out
now John one of the things that I think
we would massively benefit from in this
country is Australia's understanding of
how to deal with immigration
because
we don't seem we we are completely
paralyzed as I'm sure you've noticed in
this country and in America but this
country particularly interests me
because the similarities are so strong I
mean how an island is incapable of
ensuring that it has borders is frankly
Beyond me and you were part of a
government yes under John Howard yes
that actually addressed this issue not
an easy issue to address it was a very
unpleasant and difficult things to do
we have the Home Secretary in this
country attempting to deal with it
um being called racist and all the rest
of it tell tell everybody first of all
how you guys did it and what are some of
the lessons that you think people in
this country who want to see immigrants
like me come in and make their
contribution who don't want to see
people discriminated against but also
don't happen to think that people coming
illegally in boats is the right approach
how does how does one navigate that
with enormous difficulty and with a lot
of misunderstanding being bandied around
I think as part of the process and I
don't take it lightly at all because I
don't want to be seen as somehow
uh not concerned for humanitarian values
but the first thing I'd say is that I
think it's important
that countries maintain their cultural
cohesion
and
I think your former prime minister Blair
was onto something when he said was it
may not have been Blair one of your
former Prime Ministers made the
interesting observation
that
one of the there should be a bigger
effort to try and help the people who
are wanting to escape their own
countries to develop
better more coherent societies of their
own to try and encourage them to build
Democratic models that respect
differences and don't squeeze people out
and that create wealth and jobs and
opportunity and in many ways
it'll often be economic immigrants you
know that become they feel like boat
people and they're needed at home their
skills and abilities are needed at home
and can't we find better ways to support
them
um
I always believe that Australia should
take in a lot of refugees and we're
never given much credit for that we
actually take have one of the highest on
a pro Rudder basis Refugee intakes in
the world far above politically correct
New Zealand it's always painted as a
hero in this matter who actually does
the heavy lifting on compassion turns
out to be Australia not the more
politically correct as in public
perception country uh not far away from
us so I'd have to say that to my New
Zealand friends but you know you've got
to look at the facts the facts matter
um no they don't yeah
I thought we'd found some common good
value
um and uh
I I do think it's incredibly important
though to recognize
that
it's really you know with porous borders
ultimately countries can't survive so if
you want beacons of light if you want
countries that are coherent enough that
are prosperous enough that are strong
enough to then do good works abroad you
can't have them in a situation where
there's massive social unease of the
sort of shore in Germany where there's
serious economic disruption uh
and so and and and disruption to the
orderly management of people in genuine
humanitarian crisis through a properly
coordinated approach of refugee
management around the world and there
are far too many of them that tells a
terrible story about ugly regimes you've
written about that
um well what do we want to try and do
escape the help them Escape their
terrible regime in their own homelands
build better homes
you know we were playing society's once
that none of us would have wanted to
belong to why do they want to come to
our societies
to help them build Democratic and
prosperous societies
uh and and I don't think you can do that
if you're so weakened and divide your
own communities if you make them so
incoherent that they can't be a beacon
of light or or a source of of of of of
finance and and Aid and export of
knowledge okay however you've skipped
over a really big part there John and
I'm sure it's unintentional but uh the
chances of us building a democratic
regime in Syria and in Afghanistan which
we by the way the West has destroyed uh
Etc are quite slim we do have a lot of
people also coming who are as you say
economic migrants I mean one of the
biggest sources of people into the UK at
the moment is albanians albanians a safe
country but we don't seem to be able to
deal with the fact that the people are
coming and they're not following the
rules so for example my mum wanted to
come and visit my uh wife and I to for
our son's first birthday in a few weeks
her visa application was denied because
the person in the home office decided
she doesn't have enough money or what
the visa center or whatever which is
fine you know you make an application
whatever
but at the same time they're 50 000
people a year who are coming in on a
boat without any of those checks we
don't know who they are we're paying for
them to stay in hotels that is I put it
to you completely unsustainable and that
also we have to have a solution to that
part of it as well right the illegal
immigration that's happening and that's
what you guys had to deal with hmm
yeah well we did and uh it was
controversial in Australia at the time
but we sent them and of course you've
got to remember it in Australia uh they
were coming through bad Waters and leaky
boats and there were a staggering number
of people were drowning so it was very
inhumane you had people smuggling going
on uh no doubt about that quite corrupt
and very cruel and dangerous and so we
were able to stop that by simply
ensuring they did not get onto the
mainland they were processed offshore
what people miss when they say
Australia's been terrible here is the
very high Refugee immigrant from your
point and we bought it in an ordered way
based on properly assessed need
to give those people some Hope from the
really troubled parts of the world
so I'm not pretending it's easy I'm not
trying to duck it either you seem
uncomfortable about this are you oh yeah
yeah I'm uncomfortable about it I can't
stand the thought of people suffering
yeah but I also know that you know
you've got to keep your own culture
coherent your own economy coherent
you've got to stand against evil regimes
and you got to somehow rather despite
what you say and you're right in some
parts of the world this is nearly an
impossible dilemma and I I think we've
got 40 million refugees in various camps
and staging parts around the world maybe
we need to all take more but it's got to
be an orderly process
it has to be otherwise you're so weak in
our societies both socially and
economically that they start to lose
their ability to really insist on change
and to finance that change and make it
all if you like as coherent as possible
I think that discomfort you experience
is actually a much more honest position
that than the vast majority of people on
both sides you have people here at least
you know who to say well we you know
these people are suffering and we must
we must help them which of course we
want to on the other hand there are
people on the right who say no keep
everybody out uh and you you your
conflict internally is actually
reflective of I think where the majority
of the people are which is they think
people should follow the rules and they
also think the rules should allow people
who in genuinely need to be able to come
the problem is once you get into the
Practical side of it it's all hard
choices all the way very hard choices
but here's a fundamental problem we
don't believe enough in our own cultural
values to say that we've got to keep
them coherent and together if we're to
be a beacon to the rest of the world and
I think that's a big part of it we don't
draw a distinction enough of a
distinction between you know I'm going
to use this word the nobility of the
democratic ideal
and the appalling nature of the regimes
that these people are trying to escape
and that's my point I put it poorly but
one of your former Prime Ministers was
very big on this idea I heard quite a
cogent argument from him once and I just
can't remember who it was about how we
have to redouble our efforts uh even if
we've got to take them in uh into a
staging Camp somewhere to pick up those
people who have skills and abilities and
then somehow try and feed them back
wherever we can into their own country
to rebuild those and of course it's
happened from time to time there are
countries that have found their way out
of me you could argue that of our own
culture I'm a Scottish background I mean
there are about five warring tribes that
murdered one another across Scotland
until probably really the coming of a
Christian reformation and they all
started to recognize that it's not not a
very uh Christian thing to do to
slaughter one another and they gradually
began to change their behavior this does
happen
once upon a time you would have said we
were not good candidates to live in
peaceful Democratic societies
we need to keep sight I think of the
essential beliefs and values and not to
cry and to base them so much time that
gave us those things
and then redouble our efforts to extend
them but because we don't believe in
them anymore
in 30 years since the fall of the Berlin
War when we thought democracy had one
one out and it was on the advance it's
now in the retreat
we need to redouble our our confidence
in ourselves I think and our commitment
I'm deeply invested in trying to help
people in the majority world and help
them find their way out of poverty
through food production for example an
Australian Australia is one of the
biggest Heavy Hitters in this regard
because we know about farming in tough
environments one Australian farmer now
we're told feeds 700 people
uh and exporting some of that knowledge
has helped us globally Australia's just
been one of the players Britain's been
another we don't give ourselves enough
credit for this stuff
um along with the Gates Foundation the
big heady Heavy Hitters we're feeding
five billion miles a day more now than
we were 50 years ago and proportionately
the number of people who are
malnourished and stunted children and so
forth they're still too high but
proportionately they're way down the
good news stories about what we can do
to help lift people out of short nasty
brutish lives if we have enough
confidence in ourselves and our
opportunity to help others and enough
respect for their Humanity to do it in
an orderly and sensible way
John we're talking about regimes there's
one regime that Australia is
uncomfortably enmesh with and that's
China how worried are you about that
very worried now I'm extremely worried
about it just as I'm learning about the
Ukraine I'd love to hear your views and
we can talk about that later you know we
have no exit plan we don't seem to know
how whether it may escalate what it may
ultimately become you'll know more about
that than more than me I want to say
first up this is so important
um I admire the Chinese people I think
what they've achieved is incredible
um the West has been responsible for a
lot of that we've been great markets
we've given them a lot of Technology uh
the Democratic and capitalist models
being applied to their economy and that
has lifted a lot of people out of short
nasty brutish lives that's all good
stuff but they've got another export
from the West a thing called communism
in Beijing
and of course the Communist thing is
about you know it's it's a flawed model
people say oh communism is a great deal
again Constantine you'll know more about
this than me uh but it's just never been
properly applied no it's a flawed
concept because it says that we human
beings will give our first loyalty to
the party
you've got a son you're not going to
give your first loyalty to a political
party over your loyalty to your son
and it's but it's got this model that
demands all loyalty to it
and as part of that seems to have to
expand its power and its influence
everywhere
and that's a real dilemma and we need to
be very very conscious
of the dangers of a regime that wants
all power unto itself that's engaged in
the most rapid armaments build up
certainly in my lifetime
and what are they up to
well certainly massive interference
technological political social
everywhere they now have uh more ships
in their Navy than the American Navy who
would have thought that possible a few
years ago the Americans I suspect still
have greater tonnage and greater
sophistication on that sort of front
they are determined I think to find a
way to reunify Taiwan well I don't
believe that a people should be denied
the right to self-determination the time
of news people have decided to be a
democracy
just like the people in Hong Kong did
and and and we should defend that
principle that's Freedom that's the
right to determine the sort of lives in
society that you want to live in these
things are of immense value and we
should treasure them more in the west
you've written a book about it
although I could also play The Devil's
Advocate argument which is
I mean democracy great but you've got to
be able to defend it and if you can't
you know do you want America
deep into China's Backwater interfering
and what the Chinese see there's there
on internal affairs would would the
Americans like if the Chinese got
involved in it you know
in an equivalent thing in the United
States do you see what I'm saying
uh look I've heard the argument quite
often I'm sure but I still say that time
on uh the time when these people have
determined that they want to be
democratic
uh uh I still say that whoever controls
in the end of the South China Seas will
control things like the internet for
example because of the there are
hundreds of cables through that region
are we going to keep it free for the
exchange of information and commerce and
and the free flying of a world where we
thought we were building a better model
for peaceful coexistence and trade and
interaction or we go into a hand control
to a regime that is playing the intent
upon dominating the region
so what does Australia do then John
because Australia has got very rich with
Chinese investment with Chinese buying
your products buying your minerals
how do you break away from that can you
well only by I mean you know we must not
wish the Chinese people ill and that
trade's been very important to them it's
helped lift a lot of those people out of
those short British lives sorry to
repeat that don't uh and we want to
build a Cooperative model and keep it
you know we should play with a straight
bat at all times
and we should try to be good citizens
but we also need to club together
globally Lee Kuan Yew from the Singapore
uh Miracle story and I wrote 20 years
ago
that in the end China will have the
ability to Simply Flex economic muscle
and bring everybody to heal unless we
club together
and you are seeing that and it's really
important that in our region Japan and
Australia in particular have said look
we do believe in our values and so we
talked a little while ago about covert
in Australia and Australians being a bit
too but give us some respect I think for
being
pretty straight up and down and saying
no we do we are willing to defend our
way of life and we're not going to have
Chinese interference in our universities
our political parties and yes we are
going to take Army seriously and we are
going to club together under orcas with
the Brits and the Americans to share
Technologies and to upgrade submarine
capacity and those sorts of things
um and you're now seeing that that model
flows through into a greater willingness
across Asia to say well we don't have to
subject to a regime that doesn't look
like it's particularly interested in
open Democratic models so the
Philippines have stepped up
for example India is engaging and India
will supply China over time as a bigger
country and probably a bigger economy
China in many ways is peaking
you know they've got massive problems
with debt uh their population is about
it is leading the depopulation bomb
it's extraordinary it's anticipated that
its population may go from 1.3 1.4
billion down to five or 600 million by
the end of this century
um and so I think again I really stress
yes our relationship with the Chinese
people and their trade has been good for
them good for us
um yes we do have some differences
with the Communist model of governance
and their intention on domination we'd
rather cooperation
but at the same time recognize that we
do still believe in our own bad it's
just as you've done in Europe in
relation to the Ukraine
that's what it's been about and that
must have given great pause I would have
certainly in Moscow but in Beijing as
well they wouldn't have expected this
level of cooperation economic as well as
military
and per se presumably that's you know
cause something of a rethink I hope it
has
John we're going to continue the
conversation uh on our locals with our
paid supporters with their questions but
for now thank you so much for coming on
the show
it's always a pleasure to speak with you
and our last question is always the same
which is what is the one thing that
we're not talking about as a society
that you think we really should be
I'll surprise you there I actually think
it's fatherlessness
that doesn't surprise me yeah no I think
it is an absolute crisis and I think we
have caught our children up in in the
culture wars
in a way that frankly reflects very very
poorly on Western Society I think it's a
real blight and I think we need to lift
our game and say
our children who are relatively
voiceless
need to come first in our considerations
as to what their needs are not our
conveniences and what suits us
because I think particularly for young
men right across the West fatherlessness
the lack of good role modeling the lack
of
demonstration of how to respect uh women
properly and so forth and all the raw
figures are there with the you know the
young men who drop out who end up
traumatized depressed anxious self-harm
and prison and just dropping out of the
system it ought to be worrying us and if
one's sex is not doing well neither sex
is doing as well as an order in my view
John it's been absolutely brilliant
thank you so much for coming on the show
uh where can people find you online no
at johnanderson.net are you but uh it's
very kind of you you've been able to
understand my Australian accent have you
yes just a little bit got the odd words
yeah and of course your YouTube show
which is conversations with John
Anderson head on over to locals for the
bonus questions we'll see you there
Emma says what has shocked you most
about the trajectory of Australian
politics since you left off it
[Music]